i can't believe i'm gonna do this hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's
[Music]
kitchen in today's video we'll be taking
a look and trying the diet of model and
mega influencer haley bieber but first
let me tell you about my sponsor aura as
someone who works full-time online i
have a lot of details about my personal
life out there on the web in 2020 alone
49 million americans were victims of
identity theft identity theft is not a
joke jim which has cost him a combined
56 billion dollars i mean this is
affecting someone every 14 seconds every
day that is terrifying and it's not just
happening to folks who make really
crappy passwords or are victims of
convincing scams 37 billion records were
hacked in 2020 alone mainly from places
like social media sites so this is why
partnering with aura was so important to
me aura's app uses ai and machine
learning to protect your identity online
you just tell aura what email addresses
account numbers and phone numbers you
want to protect and it'll use their
algorithms to monitor for critical
activity the app also features a vpn
that encrypts your browsing history and
lets you stay anonymous online plus they
have antivirus software to block malware
and viruses since signing myself up aura
has found my personal information five
times so if you want to try ora yourself
you can get a 14 day free trial by going
to aura.com
abby sharp and leave a comment below
with how many times aura has flagged
your personal information online and you
can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always feel
free to skip this video if it is not
supportive to your journey and if you
are not already subscribed here hit that
subscribe button and follow me over on
tik tok and instagram at abby's kitchen
so i read a lot of gossip magazines and
what i've seen is that haley bieber's
diet tends to follow some standard celeb
dye rules according to news reports and
interviews she eats lots of veg she
prioritizes fish and poultry over red
meat and she avoids the typical baddies
like gluten dairy and added sugar her
and everybody else in la i guess i
thought we would do things differently
today and i would attempt her meals for
the day
making my own
let's just say
tweaks as i see fit but first i want to
just unpack the fad diet that she
credits to helping support her low iron
levels 90s kids you know where i'm going
with this we've got to talk about the
blood type diet brody can i get like an
eye roll mean please oh boy
so the blood type diet first got
popularized back in 1996 by naturopathic
doctor peter damo with the release of
his book eat right for your type and the
theory is that different blood types
process foods differently so following a
specific diet can allegedly improve
digestion maintain body weight increase
energy levels improve mental clarity and
prevent disease so it's no surprise that
given its laundry list of health claims
and woo-woo
that this diet has continued to gain
traction among celebrity diet circles as
the secret to longevity when looking at
the random rules assigned to different
blood types i guess i would assume that
haley is following the diet for blood
type b as she consumes a variety of
plant foods and meat and no dairy
there's also a lot of random rules like
avoiding corn wheat buckwheat lentils
tomatoes peanuts and sesame seeds which
seem to line up with what i've read
about haley's eating habits but is the
blood type diet
even legit so according to datamo his
book was based on decades of ongoing
research it seems that since the release
of this book almost three decades ago
the research must mysteriously still be
ongoing aka
because i only found three studies on
blood type diets and let's just say they
aren't very convincing for example one
systematic review looked at whether
adhering to a blood type diet can
improve health and lower disease risk
one study included in the review did
find improvements in cholesterol levels
after following a low fat diet according
to blood types however this study did
not characterize the group by the [ __ ]
blood type which is what dynamo uses but
rather uses mns blood types which are
functionally different so not
surprisingly this evidence does not
confirm anything about datamost claims
another large study looking specifically
at the [ __ ] blood type diet found that
those following the type a plant-based
diet had improvements in cholesterol
blood sugar management and weight loss
but
and this is a big butt oh my god becky
look at her butt it is so big the same
health impacts were also observed in
other blood type groups similarly a 2020
randomized control trial found that an
individual's blood type made no
difference in health outcomes when
adhering to a type a plant-based diet in
other words a predominantly plant-based
diet is healthy for anyone and this is
well documented in the literature
regardless of an individual's blood type
so now that we know that the blood type
die is surprise surprise bs come with me
to attempt to eat like a bieber
supermodel
please
let there be some bread so according to
haley in her interviews
she says that breakfast is usually eggs
or oatmeal
some type of healthy protein or a
smoothie all right
i don't love all the ores going on in
this statement because i think we're
going to need more ants so i'm going to
do eggs in oatmeal
a la my famous protein oats this is a
staple abby's kitchen recipe all the
og's know it all the og's love it so
you're going to love it too
and i think we're going to have a
protein smoothie on the side so we got
protein fat and fiber rich carbs let's
do it okay so shameless plug here this
is my book the mindful glow cookbook you
can buy it
on amazon or at your favorite bookstore
it's been well loved um so we're going
to do my whipped protein oats or protein
oatmeal this is the little picture you
can do it any way you want i'm just
going to use whatever i've got in hand
and it's got the benefits of having the
oatmeal plus the eggs that apparently
haley really likes so
first thing we're going to do
just whisk this up a little bit
just to get a little frothy we get a
little morning workout in
that's good
that was a lot
okay
let's get some oats in the pot
[Applause]
i got a scoop in here
in
about a cup and a half
oats always need cinnamon and salt
i don't always need cinnamon but
mine do
that's enough
let's
spark up a dub
okay
so now i'm going to just do this
all right keep whisking
let's squish whisper
swiss swiss whisper
swiss just
trust me
this oatmeal bowl will change your life
i'm like so excited for this
all right then i got
a banana
banana haters you can omit the banana
this is really just for some extra
carbohydrates flavor natural sweetness
and i really like bananas so i use a lot
of bananas in my recipes a little
vanilla
let's
get that all squished down
mash her up
one last stir make sure all them
chunkers are dealt with and the lid
goes on
i also promised you guys a smoothie so
we're going to do that
we've got frozen banana
run away
it's good
we got
some frozen cherries
grown spinach
peanut butter it's like the largest most
aggressive
sized peanut butter jug
but i am here for it
i was storing it upside down to get that
oil incorporated
and put a lot in there
and parts
and now we pray that there's enough
space for some milk
i feel like we can close that lid
and we'll see
look how fluffy
and dreamy this is
little chunks of banana
it's like a huge pot of oats
and it's all for me
haley you gotta try this girl even if
you don't like eggs let me tell you you
don't taste like eggs a lot of people
ask me will this taste like eggs
absolutely not read all the comments on
my blog there's a blog post with this
recipe it's one of my number one recipes
for a reason everyone swears it does not
taste like eggs just tastes like a dream
an oatmeal dream
a little bit of
pb
hi hi friend
[Music]
you know if you know you know
we'll do blueberries
all right
off like a good bread yes those are the
strawberries for me and you
smoothie
i like it thick
now obviously if i had more room in my
smoothie jar i would have added more
milk but i didn't because i got a little
too excited about all the other
ingredients
so it's going to be
a spoonable
smoothie and i'm okay with that too
fluffy
and the banana adds so much natural
sweetness i don't even like really sweet
things so
i don't think i even need extra maple
syrup or honey on top but you can
totally add it as well
let me get a straw
oh it's good it tastes like ice cream
haley
get at me you won't be mad
[Music]
huge upgrade from the eggs or oatmeal
situation don't you agree so according
to haley's interviews she says that
lunch is usually salad
fish grilled veggies or maybe a sandwich
i don't really eat a lot of gluten so
i'm trying to be particular i love a
good kale caesar salad with no croutons
that's usually one thing i leave out
that's like the best part rip croutons r
i
p so let's do it my way we're going to
have
kale
caesar dressing i'm going to add some
chicken on top for our protein and i'm
going to load that up with croutons
and we're gonna have with some crusty
bread and avocado on the side love it
let's make our own croutons
so
i have this delicious
blackbird sourdough bread if you know
you know
it is the best in toronto
but it's on its last legs here she's
getting a little
dry but i see no mold so we're gonna
make croutons with it that's what we do
so let me grab my
candy
bread knife
i'm gonna
just start to
put that into some crouton like shapes
as big or small as you desire
choose your own crouton adventure
get them coated in some of that butter
and oil so they can get crispy
and need lots of salt
it's kind of the point they got to be
like salty that's my favorite reason for
a good croutons the salt factor
all right let's just let them do their
thing all right i'm just trying to get
some of the leaves off my kale here
here's a dietician confession i don't
really like kale
like
it's okay
i'll eat it if it's there
it does not have like superpower status
in my books though definitely no more
than any other you know green vegetable
and if i'm really honest
it hurts my tongue so i definitely limit
consumption this is going to be
um
not an everyday meal for me but i'm
going to make the best out of it by
adding in
like lots of caesar dressing and just
kind of cutting it up as fine as i
possibly can to make it a little easier
on my digestion
oh yeah
okay i feel like this is good
we'll let them sit chill
and cut up some kale
yeah i cut it up like super fine
definitely helps with the digestion for
me and like no one wants to eat a kale
cell where there's just like huge pieces
of
of gnarly lettuce just like hanging out
their gob
i'm sure you can find a meme for this
brody that of you know
someone eating something nice and classy
like that
are you thinking jim carrey yeah jim
carrey that's not exactly who what movie
was that the mask
either the mask or the face venture
always says ventura for sure
[Music]
yeah he perfected
the uh
the not so polite dinner guest look
oh did you watch um
talking about memes i was first my
sister we growing up my favorite movie
was pb herman's big adventure have you
ever watched that i don't think i've
ever seen that actually you actually
should just watch it because the number
of meme
options in there
are it's one of the best movies ever
made and it's
literally hilarious
someone interrupting my
he won't come back we won't be getting
any more mail forevermore canada post is
just put me on the blacklist psychopath
okay well there's a lot
of
kale here
so let's make a little salad shall we
let's start with
a solid amount of dressing we got some
fat here
i never really know how much dressing to
do so i gotta start
like a modest amount
and then we can add more if needed
but with any kind of kale
lettuce situation
you just gotta get in there with your
hands and feel around and massage it in
and give it some love and
i don't have bacon well she didn't
mention bacon i have a feeling she
doesn't eat bacon
i eat bacon uh but we're going to skip
the bacon today because we've got
chicken for our protein
and tons of cheese as well i actually
think we can add a little more
with the dressing looks good
yum
yum yum yum yum got our rotisserie
chicken here
as we always do some mom staple we
always got to have rotisserie chicken in
the house and just gonna add that right
on top because
i rarely make
lunches from scratch this is about as
much work as i have capacity to do and
the fact that i made [ __ ] croutons
like
i deserve an award mom of the year right
here mom of the year all right all this
going in
run away
run away
uh we need a clean tons
and
some more cheese
guys this is like not gonna be enough
for me for lunch so i'm also gonna get
some nice crusty
bread and put some avocado on top
because i feel like that's something
that haley would like maybe without the
bread just the avocado
i'm forcing curbs on this girl i'm going
to encourage it carbs
are
life so is cheese that's why i like lots
of it and you see this i know she said
no croutons but your girl needs a
crouton i need a lot of croutons
so
is there any point in just like saving
these
no
might be a little over the edge in terms
of the traditional ratio but
i'm always
excited
about a salad that has like lots of
croutons
that's why i love a panzanella salad
it's basically a bread salad what's not
to love hey this actually looks really
good setting it aside to make a little
bit of toast okay
they get
let's just slice this bad boy
nice question of the day do i have
a good
avocado i gotta use my avocado psychic
feels
good
this one's energy is pulling me that's
the one
do not
steer me wrong i've got an audience here
guys
moment of truth
oh
yes
i was right i was right as can be should
i toss this i should
that is delicious
okay a little
fancy salt
and
you know what
since i've got the perm out you might as
well give it the royal treatment
never going to say no to cheese
i don't know about you but i feel like
this is an enormous upgrade from just a
plain kale caesar salad
without croutons we got our protein we
got our fat we got fiber-rich carbs in
the play
and i also got some toast as well
the croutons
slap so according to haley she says that
dinner is usually kind of along the same
lines as lunch
some sort of vegetable or pasta like a
gluten-free pasta i do hope that it's
not a vegetable
or pasta but it definitely gives me
a nice amount of creative freedom in the
kitchen and in spite of the stupid blood
type diet rules i'm gonna use tomatoes
here because i love tomatoes all right
let's see what we got in the pantry and
fridge to make a quick little pasta
dinner for haley
represent i did get a gluten-free pasta
um it's chickpea pasta which we actually
already love here in my house so
it's gonna work
all right so we need some vegetables
in this pasta this is just what i've got
on hand i've got some more of that kale
which we can wilt down
and i got a zucchini which i will chop
and saute
i've also got some chicken sausage here
my kids love this sausage
don't know how i discovered it i think
an instacart
shopper
gave me this instead of normal fresh
sausage and the rest is history now the
kids love it so whatever i'm going to
just kind of cut this into some pieces
you can pan fry that
yum
if you're wondering why i don't add
peppers because my kids will see the
pepper and they will be
horrified
and turned off so we have to add all the
spice at the end to the adult plate
in my house
good waiting for the snacks aren't you
yes you are yes
all right let's just let that
do its thing
a little that kale i already cut up
might as well get it used up
rough
okay let's put some sauce in
white beans for some extra protein and
fiber we love that looking good
oh no
why do i wear nice things
honestly
okay so just checking that it's at a
rolling boil
yes
go to bed my little pasta deers
go to bed does the sound of a metal
utensil
in a pot
make you cringe just a little bit okay
this just needs some cheese
and we are in play
all right let's serve her up i'm excited
this smells
out of control and obviously it's a lot
more satisfying and satiating than just
vegetables
or gluten-free pasta so we've got
protein in our sausage in our beans
we've got fats in our avocado oil that i
use for cooking plus in the cheese we
got carbs here that are rich in fiber in
the chickpea pasta and our vegetables
and a little bit of bread on the side
i'm really excited to dig in
so good tomatoes are life
so
what are my thoughts here
well i get that this interview was like
vegas and also we cannot confirm or deny
whether or not this is truthfully how
she eats every single day this is a
secondary source but i would say that
this diet as written
can definitely use some pizzazz or at
least some rule bending seeing as the
blood type diet is total bunk there's no
good evidence to cut out tomatoes or
lentils because you're type b and in
haley's case specifically since it seems
that iron intake and anemia is a concern
for her i would way rather her focus on
getting in as many iron-rich food
sources as she possibly can rather than
cutting some key ones out like lentils
and nuts because her blood type says she
should ditto for some easy sources of
vitamin c like tomatoes which can
enhance the absorption of iron as for
her meals there are a lot of like i'd
have this or that when i think that most
women her age and size would need both
or at least like very large portions of
one so i hope i gave you guys some
inspiration on how to bulk up on some of
these pseudo meals to make them more
satiating and satisfying and on that
note that's all that i have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with what or who you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]